Tom you a reason presented at the Oscars
I did yes and then afterwards as if that
wasn't enough after it you met well one
of the most famous people in the world
one of the most famous women in the
world I had one of the most embarrassing
experiences with Madonna I was at the
Oscars I presented it went well you know
I went out afterwards to sort of
celebrate and have a good time I
probably had one too many and I was at
this party with a couple of my friends
and an old friend of mine who's a
manager comes up to me and he's like Tom
Tom Tom do you know Madonna and I'm like
funnily enough no so he goes come with
me come with me come with me so he drags
me across this nightclub and introduces
me to Madonna now the whole way on the
way over there I'm going what do I say
hello I had no idea what to say so I get
up there and I go hello we're not how
you doing I'm good thank you I'm well
and Jason can see me panicking and goes
Madonna tom is an incredible dancer imma
kill you and she goes really well that's
something I'd love to see show me I have
two options right I can just faint or I
can take Madonna into the dance floor
dance with her and show her my moves and
just have a great time sure you know no
being an idiot I went for option two and
I sort of dragged her into the dance
floor and as soon as I took her I
realized either this was a mistake I
used to be Billy Elliot and I used to do
a lot of dancing but that was all
choreographed you know I didn't wing it
I didn't start dancing with her and and
there's not much arms involved I'm just
sort of doing a little two-step to try
and like warm myself up and she's so
unimpressed so unimpressed that I just
bailed and left
you shiny maintaining honor in the
docile
the next day I'm telling my family on
FaceTime who's having a family dinner
about my evening and the Oscars they
wanted to know where the gosh and I end
up telling them the story my dad is
wetting himself
my mother is cringing and then my little
brother paddy goes who's McDonough
[Applause]
[Music]
you